abone ol
bu
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Merhaba paketten arabası Merhaba ismim
Eren Sen çapraz sitesinde yani sizin
senin hepinizin Lisesi 11-c sınıfı bugün
kolunuz hayatın kırılma noktalarıyla Ben
de bugün deneyiminden bahsedeceğim yani
hayatında ne yaşadım bu anne kaptı ve
Kırılma Noktası ne bundan biraz
bahsedeceğim şimdi ilk olarak soruyla
başlamak istiyorum Yani herkes burada
bir nokta doğru yüzü burada ben
doğduğumdan beri aynı bebek gibi her
zaman aynı düşünüyorum gelecek bir var
ya zaman ben hiç değiştirme diyen var mı
Ben Evet Tahmine yok Çok da yok ya
olmaması doğru olmaz tabiki Çünkü zaman
dediğimiz şey değişken yani Bir saniye
bir sonraki ile aynı değil asla ve Ya
aslında güzel bir şey Çünkü bizim şu an
kişiliğimizi oluşturan zamanın
ilerlemesi ve bizi değiştirir sürece
benim de değişimi sürecim Aslında
İzmir'den İstanbul'a taşınmaya başladı
Ben İzmir'deyken ilkokul çağında Aydın
Ortaokulu kadar oradaydım ve kendi
sporcusu insan olarak tanımlayabilirim
yani elime gelen her fırsatta farklı
sporları dedim bu Afiyet olsun wintrac
Olsun bir sürü elimden geldiğince spor
verdim Bugün ablam dedi ki Erhan Sen
baskete başla ve benim baskete başladı
Çünkü kendisi O zaman da basket
takımının kaptanıyla kızlarda Ben de
dedim Tamam başlıyorum ben bahset olmaya
başladı kendimi işte akşam ablamla
giderek basket Alıştırdım elimde işte
topla gezdim ve bir süreden sonra
oynayabildiği fark ettim dedim ki ben
takıma gireyim bir tane seçmeye gittim
seçme gittikten sonra takımdaki Koç beni
al dışarı ve oradaki Sayın 15 kişi ipi
takım haline geldi ya ben de tabii ki
mutlu oldum çok yani işte antreman aldı
oraya ihanet çalışıyorum bulmalıyım ama
antrenman olurken bakıyorum iki ayrı yok
[ __ ] sonet Ben kalıyoruz yap tamam ben
takım dedim pek çalışıyorum yapıyorum
Bir akşam antrenman kaçırmamaya özen
gösteren bir insan olduğum için hani
Sonra kalırım genelde ve bir akşam
birazcık geç çıktım çıkarken koçmana gel
dedi ki Herhangi bir dakika dedi Yazdı
bana dedi ki Eren basket sana göre değil
sen basket oyna başka bir şey yok ben o
süreçte İzmir'de farklı bir ve taşıyorum
veya orada hiçbir şey diyemedim eve
gittim evde takılıyoruz parça yaptım
dedim ki Allah kahretsin ağlamaya
başladım
elden sorunlarını çok da böyle dile
getiren bir insan değilim Anneme babama
ablana karşı bir tane kaybedebilirsiniz
zaten bana sordular ben anlatmadım işte
Eren ne oldu hani gerçekten merak
ettiler niye bu kadar alıyor O da
anlattım sonra beni cenaze sorunları
Aslında aksiyonun açılmaya davet eden
insanlar yani gidip ona Koçlar
konuşmaktansa Dediler ki bana Eren sana
o zaman o kadar çalışacaksın ki yine bu
sene sonunda kurşuna kanıtlayacak sın
Ben oynayabiliyoruz aynı takımın en iyi
en iyisi olmak istiyor Yani en iyisinde
demediler Ama sen o takımın parçası ve
bunu göstereceksiniz lan ben de o andan
itibaren
gerçekten o motivasyonda tüm geceler
elime Topal'ın ablamı zorladım hep
birlikte antrenman yapmaya başladı babam
bana şu tadı işte topu veriyor Ben şu
takıyorum Akşama yapıyoruz fakat sene
sonuna kadar tam göstereceğim dediğim
anda bir taşınma evresi yazdı annem ve
Ablam bana bir gün Geldi Dediler ki e
lan işler güzel sevdin mi Ben dedim ki
İstanbul'un neresi Yani ben ilkokulları
bilmiyorum ceza ki güzel sözler şerefsiz
değilim
Ben de Ya hayır ya niye gidelim falan
beni arkadaşlarım var okulun şey sabit
gayet güzel bir şeyler vardır rahat
olduğum yalan arası Alışığım geldik
ister O yaşta sonuçlar kısıtlılığı mız
var bununla küçük kapanırsa diğer sokup
Tamamdır zorlanıyoruz ben araba dayısı
şey uyandım böyle artık Sabah erken
Merhaba İstanbul'a geldik Ben
de tabii ki dediklerini doğru olduğunu
anladım oğlum dedim ki A ne yapacağım
etrafa bakıyorum sağına soluna bakayım
hiçbir şey bilmiyorum insanlara
bakıyorum asla tanımadığım diğer ve
okula başlamam gerekiyor bir hafta sonra
okula başlıyorum isim okula kimseyi
tanıyor yani onu anladım dedim ki ben
burada Hayallerim kobi'lerin ve ailem
değil başka hiçbir şey yok ve
kısıtlanmış yani tanışma şansım yok
kimseye der ve o kadar Alışık olduğum
bir rahat alanının içindeyim ki O da
ayağını dışarı atmak istemiyorum Bu üç
ay sürdü ablanla birbirimize sarıldık
Akşamları işte Ben anlatıyorum o bana
anlatıyor Çünkü o da bir seçim da
değiştirdi O da zorluklar yaşadı aynı
şekilde önünüze anlattıkça anlatıyoruz
ama bir nokta geldi dedi ki Hadi biz
maçımız lazım Böyle olmayacak Ve ilk
adına ablam attı neden sonuçta beni
teşvik etti Dedi ki Eren Sen bozma atmak
zorundasın çünkü aile de bir yere kadar
yani gün için birlikte değiliz Sadece
akşam üzüyoruz güneşi de okulda tek
başına bende ne yaptın bahsettim aldım
basket oynuyorum işte teneffüslerde
bahsetmiyorum bahsettiğin indikçe çevren
artık aynı mobil olduğum insanlar olduğu
için genişlemeye başladı çünkü hiçbirşey
ortak değil seninle aynı anda için orada
ise artık çalışmaya başlıyoruz bu Daha
sonrasında Bu iş biraz geliştirdim Annem
beni okula servisle değil minibüse
gönderdi okul tarafından çok değerli bir
anda Aslında neden miydik Yani bu ya bu
ilkokul çağında ya o kuşandı Tanrım
gönderisinde Hatta tepkiler geldi ama
ben her zaman Dedim ki anne Sen
doğrusunu yapıyorsun Ben de öyle
istiyorum çünkü Daha arkadan mesela abi
bir öğrenci diye bağırdığında bile
özgüvenin Aslında arttığını sesini
çıkarabileceğini görmüş oluyoruz ve ben
bu Özgüven Aslında Özgüven yükselmesiyle
TEM ablamın arkadaşlarına Hem annemin
Arkadaşlar herkese zor da olsa elini
uzatmaya başladım ve asla oradaki sosyal
ki de Binali kırıldım
ve sonrasında baskete devam ediyorum
benim basket takımı aldılar koşmaya fark
etti Dedi ki bu çünkü oynayabiliyor
Çünkü o zamandan beri elma adımı
koymadan çalışıyorum Her akşam Başka
işiniz yok yani daha küçük yaş olduğu
için Neyse bir dik ve bir nokta geldi
ben size dışarıdaki takımlarda girdim
bir nokta geldi Ben eski koçum da aynı
turnuvaya düştüm dedim ki benim adım Şu
an ben sana göstereceğim
çalışmaya devam ediyorum asla olmadığı
kadar yüksek tempoda çalışıyoruz ve
turnuvaya gittikten sonra gerçekten
maçımız geldi Ben oraya bittikten sonra
gerçekten ya O ana kadar hani takımın en
iyi oyuncusu değilim bu kesin ama o ana
kadar oğlanın görmediği şekilde yani
Koçaslan koşulsal beklemeyeceğim şekilde
öyle bir takılmaz sergiledim ki koçmana
maçtan sonra geldi ve dedi Eren çok
pardon zaten yapamazsın demiştir ama
oynuyorsun Ben de dedim ki yani var ya
dedim Bana böyle dedin ama teşekkür
ederim Çünkü benim bu yönde Sen ipten
beni motive ettin Çok teşekkür ederim
koş ve asla hayatında çok büyük bir
kırılma noktasıydı bak Çünkü hayat
Aslında başlangıç son olarak düşünmemek
gerekiyor Yani işler oluyor çıkışlar
alıyor bizi çok farklı noktaları
satılıyor ve bunu yaptıktan sonra koşuya
ayrıldık yani kötü yalnız Yok yok Daha
sonrasında Ortaokulda normal bir çocuğun
hayatı nasıl söyle devam etti lise kadar
ve bu sene 11 sınıfta ikinci büyük
kırılmam yaşandı ikinci bir kırılmam ben
herkesin seçtiği ile sayısal eşit
ağırlık sözel olarak size üç bölümden
birine yani sayısal seçtin sayısını
seçtikten sonra normal çalışıyorum
danslarını herkes gibi soruları
çözüyorum fizik hocamız olsun hoca geldi
Ona bir gün yani Çok da konuşmamız yok
yani daha kulüp tarifleri yapılmadı
sadece dakika görüyor bir gün bana gel
dedi ki evrende de Ne oldu senin bana
kazandırdığı en önemli insanlardansın
Sen bu sene çok büyük bir şey yapacaksın
ve biz sen çok şey başlayacağız Ben de
bunu düşün dedim ya ne bekliyor ki ben
de hani ortada hiçbir şey yok Benim
fikrim yok neden bahsettiğini vardır
Bilmiyorum bir hafta sonra kulüp
tarifleri geldi Ben dedim ki bana böyle
bir şey dedi ben o zaman fiziği tercih
edin çünkü ilk yaşadım tutanların aksine
birisi Bana inanıyor beni pompa
olacaksın itici bir güce sahip bana bir
motivasyon sağlıyor şu an de bu yüzden
fizik oyunu seçtim orada ilk ciddi hafta
bize bir motivasyon konuşması yapıldı
motivasyon konuşmasında bize aslında bir
gerçekten işte proje yapmanın ne kadar
önemli olduğunu vesaire bahsediniz de
ben de motive oldum dedim ki Hala
kuaförde misin bunu görüyor benden bunu
bekliyor Bir şey yapmamı istiyor ve ben
fikirlere bakmaya başladım işte
araştırma yapmaya başladım Aslında orta
bir fikir yok Ben bir ay boyunca ben
gerçekten sürekli araştırdım Ortada
hiçbir şey yok Çünkü biliyorsunuz
internet çok geleceğini 35 yıl önce
seslilaf internette bir şey var
ansiklopediye bağlı değiliz ve bir bilgi
yazdığınızda artık milyonlarca her şey
çıkıyor yani aradığınız Herşey
buluyorsunuz ve ben bir noktada
tesisatını ben Yeter artık yapmıyorum
bıraktım sonra tabii ki Volkan hocam
benden bir şey bekleme lan bırakıyorum
Bana dedi ki herhalde Pes Etme biraz
daha devam et daha derin araştır da şey
yap hani kendi Zorla biraz dedi Ben de
derinlere bakmaya başladım İşte bu daha
çok hani kendi iki hafta dedim kendini
hakkımızda tanıdım Öykü iki hafta sonra
ben bu fikri bulacağım hakikaten ay oldu
İki hafta sonra bir fikrim oldum ve Daha
sonrasında süreç tipi bulduktan sonra
bir şekilde ilerledi ve biz bu projeyi
bir rapor alma getirdik proje raporu
haline getirdikten sonra
sahneye çağrılan projeler arasına
girmişti de a Ben bunu benim Üner
farkında Yani iç içe gidip sunan
gerekiyordu şimdi oradaki problem
dışarıdan sürekli insana pişi var 80
kişi geliyor böyle onlar Beşer gruplar
geliyor ve sürekli projenin bakmam
gerekiyor ne yaptığıma dair bu da ya
iletişim anlamında sıkıntı Çünkü şöyle
bir söz var karşındakine anlıyorsun sen
bildin o'kadardır ben de buna çok
inandım Çünkü ne kadar bilgili olursam
ne kadar kendi kafamda iyi anlatsamda
karşıdaki anlatmıyor Ya anlamıyorum sen
de fark ettim ki bilgiler basit yaşaman
lazım artık kendimi açmam lazım Hani bu
kilidi açmam lazım basit konuşma üzerine
Çünkü gerçekten makarna otur gibi
anlatamazdım ve bunu yaptıktan sonra
jüri günü geldi bize şey demiştir
geliyor şimdi geliyor böyle herkesi
koşturuyor E ben halini size getirdim ki
ya dedim ben daha önce süre çıkmadım ne
yapacağım yani Kim bu işi de hani kaç
kişi 3 kişi geldi bu baktılar proje
çıktıları Ben de böyle çok güzel oldu
Gerçekten ne soracak ne diyecek
bilmiyorum hiç çıkacak Neyse adım
atacağım salondan içeri an fil var
kocaman ilk kez dediğim ortamı için baya
sesli gözleri kapağını kulakları Kapalım
dedim ki ağzımı açacağım ben konuşacağım
artık iyi ya da kötü burada sunuyoruz
Çünkü ortam bunu gerektiriyor yani Zorlu
umrumda değil artık ben bir şey yapmışım
karşıdaki bunu dinlemek için var
seviyesi ne olursa olsun dinleyeceğiz
Oradan çıktım gerçekten bu taktik işe
yaradı birinci çıktık oradan ve Türkiye
finali gittik türkiye'sinde yine aynı
sergi düzeni vardı bakalım bu sefer beş
yıl var beşiri'de Bu sefer artık şey
kompleks olmayan de yani yanımdaki bu
sefer 81 ilden proje olduğu için ve
herkesin birincisi yani için yanındakine
bakıyorum adam çok iyi sonra bakıyorum
çok iyi karşı Bugün herkes birinci ya
ben nasıl sonra çıkacağım en yeni farklı
kılan Yani bu noktada nasıl gelmiş
galiba bu noktada artık dedim ki evet bu
noktada iletişim çözecek Yani ben bu
kadar acı çektim işte iletişim konusunda
pes etmeme de ben bu kadar da artık
iyice saymam ve he de artık Tüm bu
dersleri birleştirerek Yürek
daha önce çıkan kişi birazcık üzgündü
böyle gördüm Nasılsın İyi misin Ne oldu
O belki ama benden bir şey olmaz sana
çok kötü olma daha sonra aldı
Ben de dedim ki Eren asla Takma onu
kenara itin kenara ben gidiyorum dedim
güldüm böyle yürüyen şekilde sundum ve
Türkiye ikincisi oldu Şimdi burası böyle
garip bir yani gerçekten böyle Ha bir de
engel var ama benim değinmek istediğim
şey burada hani Evet bir engel var ben
size Bugün iki tane onu anlattım bir
tanesi bir tanesi kötü Tüm bu şeyler acı
da varsa Yani biz bu bıraksa da iyi ya
da kötü fark etmeden bizim Bundan asla
ders çıkarmamız lazım yanında birleşerek
hayatınıza yeni bir göndermemiz lazım ve
Aslında biz bunları birleştirdik ç ç
ortaya bir yıldız çıkıyor Bence
hepinizin yapması gereken hayatta geri
dönüp baktığımızda bu yıldızlardan
olabildiğince çok oluşturmuş olmak ve
bizden sonraki gelenlerden Aslında
hayallerini görebilecekleri hayalleri
yolunda ilerle bilecekleri parlak
aydınlık ve güzel bir gezegen bırakmak
Hepinize çok öpüyorum
[Müzik]